Das sind wirklich absolut spektakuläre Fotos,
die wir hier heute zeigen können.
Und laut Experten- und Expertinnenmeinungen
zeigen sie mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit Leben
auf dem Mars.
Es sind wirklich Fotos, die einem den Atem
stocken lassen.
Denn sie zeigen Dinge, die mit außerirdischem
Leben erklären lassen und demnach hat es
sich bereits in den Nasa-Sonden ausgebreitet.
What?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Und wenn man sich die Fotos ansieht, dann
ist es zum einen etwas beklemmend auf einem
fremden Planeten Strukturen zu sehen, die
wirklich lebendig zu sein scheinen und zum
anderen auch faszinierend.
Und es ist zudem absolut beeindruckend wie
viele Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftlerinnen
in diesen Fotos tatsächlich Lebensformen
entdecken.
Fast alle 70 Forscherinnen und Forscher, die
sich die Fotos angesehen hatten, sahen eine
hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es sich um Leben
handeln müsse.
Auf den Fotos sind zum einen Strukturen zu
erkennen, die nur schwer anders als mit einer
Lebensform zu erklären sind und zum anderen
wiederum sehr an Lebensformen hier auf der
Erde erinnern.
Zum Beispiel auf diesen Fotos sind Formen
zu sehen, die an Pilze erinnern.
Die NASA hält zwar auch Hämatit für möglich,
ein Mineral, dass aus Eisen und Sauerstoff
besteht, also ein Oxyd.
Doch ein weiteres Bild oder genauer zwei Bilder
lassen an dieser These extrem zweifeln.
Hier ist nämlich sogar Wachstum zu entdecken.
Auf den ersten Blick haben diese beiden Bilder
nur wenig miteinander zu tun, wenn man sich
aber an den Zahlen orientiert und sie übereinander
legt, wird es spuky.
Dann ist sogar Wachstum zu erkennen.
Die Kugeln wachsen sogar während drei Marstage
vergehen und es entstehen neue.
Das ist mega verblüffend.
Aber warum ist diese Studie bisher kaum bekannt?
Entdeckt hat sie Rony Bläß vom YouTube-Kanal
Raumzeit - Vlog
der Zukunft:
Ein wenig beängstigend wird es dann aber
auch, wenn man sieht, wie diese Strukturen
von den Mars-Rovern der NASA Besitz ergriffen
haben.
Denn eigentlich ist es unter den Bedingungen
auf dem Mars unmöglich, dass etwas sich dort
ablagert, außer, ja außer es ist eine Lebensform.
Denn oxydieren kann nichts in der Marsatmosphäre.
Und so sind diese Bilder mega verblüffend.
Sie zeigen hier eine Ablagerung, die sich
zwischen Sol 2718 und Sol 2813 am Mars-Rover
Opportunity gebildet hat.
Oder hier beim Rover Curiosity.
Sie zeigen wie sich zwischen den Marstagen
Sol 51 und Sol 1089 Ablagerungen im Rover
bilden.
Was kann das sein?
Außer mit lebenden Organismen ist das eigentlich
nicht erklärbar.
Weitere Bilder von Curiosity sind noch beeindruckender:
Hier ist das Innere komplett verändert.
Es ist absolut rätselhaft oder eben nur mit
biologischen Strukturen erklärbar.
Was könnte ansonsten den Rover so befallen
und ausschließlich Innen für solche Veränderungen
sorgen?
An einem Stein auf dem Mars wurden in einem
genauso geschützten Bereich solche Veränderungen
gefunden.
Experten und Expertinnen halten Pilze oder
Flechten für deutlich wahrscheinlicher als
alles andere.
Gibt es also Leben auf dem Mars.
Es ist ein weiteres Puzzlestück, dass die
Wahrscheinlichkeit steigen lässt und was
ich an dieser Studie spannend finde.
Sie tendiert schon sehr zu außerirdischem
Leben.
Und ich sehe hier genauso den Punkt, den auch
Professor Abraham Loeb anführt: Wenn das
Mögliche als Lösung ausscheidet, bleibt
nur noch das Unmögliche, obwohl vielleicht
ist eben Leben im Weltall gar keine Ausnahme
und dann wäre dieser Fund eben gar nicht
so außergewöhnlich, wie wir heute noch glauben.
Noch mehr zu diesem Thema gibt es bei Raumzeit
- Vlog der Zukunft.
Draufklicken, anschauen und natürlich Raumzeit
Vlog der Zukunft abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!